All I said is we should bail on the hike.
I didn’t mean us in general.
You don’t want to make our relationship better?
Our relationship is fine.
Schmigadoon?
♫ Welcome to our little town
I hate musicals.
It must be something they do for tourists.
Ha ha ha!
Was that a leprechaun?
We’re in an actual musical.
Please god, no.
Everybody!
You know musicals.
There’s got to be a way.
We are only here 'til we've found true love.
What does that even mean?
Which of you ladies wants to cross this bridge with me?
You want to try with other people?
We already tried together.
I want to be with you.
What a beautiful couple you two make.
I don’t like those outsiders.
They need to go.
Ladies, can I get a cackle?
Where the men are men and the cows are cows ♫
You have one heart.
Is he the one you want to give it to?
I am so sorry.
I love you.
Have you forgotten what these sinful city folk
have done to this town?
They’ve made Schmigadoon better.
For everyone.
Let’s head back home.